good evening everyone on behalf of the
Tattered Cover bookstore it's my
pleasure to welcome you and to thank you
for supporting independent bookstores
Viviane Spitz is a fellow of the Academy
of professional reporters of the
National Court Reporters Association and
was an official reporter of debates and
chief reporter in the United States
House of Representatives from 1972 until
1982 in 1978 she reported President
Carter's establishment of the
President's Commission on the Holocaust
appointing world famous Holocaust
survivor and later Nobel laureate Elie
Wiesel as chairman by contract with the
United States War Department mrs. Fitz
reported the Nuremberg war crimes trial
trials in Germany from 1946 until 1948
since 1987 she Ed's has made
presentations on the Nazi doctor doctors
case to over 45,000 students and adults
in the United States Canada and
Singapore in recognition of her
presentations to refute the claims of
Holocaust deniers
she has received five national
humanitarian awards on December 22nd
1995 the Steven Spielberg visual history
foundation conducted a videotaped
interview of her as a witness to history
in April 2001 the late Tony Randall
producer of judgment at Nuremburg on
Broadway had her appear on stage
following a performance to speak on
April 25th 2005 she appeared on CNN's
Aaron Brown news night launching the
publication of her book doctors from
Hell the horrific account of Nazi
experiments on humans the book is now in
the University of Colorado medical
school bookstore and is in the deadly
medicine exhibited at the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum until October
15th on the cover of the third edition
now being printed will appear Elie
Wiesel's endorsement as follows read
vivian spit
his personal memoir with its shattering
memories from the Nuremberg trials and
you will encounter physicians who
corrupted by Nazi ideology brought shame
to their profession after tonight's
presentation Vivian will be glad to
answer questions and sign copies of her
book we are honored and delighted the
Vivian Spitz is with us this evening
would you please join me now in making
her feel welcome
[Applause]
thank you very much for inviting me to
speak to you this evening on the Nazi
doctors case of the Nuremberg war crimes
trials I want to just tell you a bit
about how I came to report these trials
in Nuremberg at such a young age
in 1905 a Spanish born harvard-educated
philosopher named George Santayana wrote
a five volume work entitled the life of
Reason in it he stated those who cannot
remember the past are condemned to
repeat it and for years now a mission of
mine has been to speak about that past
to which Santa Anna referred especially
to all who were born after 1945 the year
the Nuremberg war crimes trials
commenced these trials from November
1945 through April 1949 were the first
international criminal trials in all of
history with four countries the United
States France Great Britain and the
Soviet Union trying the leaders of one
country Germany for crimes against
humanity and calculated genocide
perpetrated over a period of 12 years
from 1933 when Adolf Hitler came to
power until 1945 when world war ii ended
these trials were concerned with three
major points basic human rights and the
dignity of life the difference between
good and evil and indifference to evil
in a
crime there is always the perpetrator
and the victim look the other way don't
get involved remain silent and you will
always help the perpetrator and never
the victim by the end of World War two
on May 8 1945 most of the major Nazi
leaders who had not already committed
suicide were in the hands of US and
British troops rather than stand them up
against the wall and shoot them on the
spot or try them immediately in summary
proceedings the United States among the
big four powers pushed for a fair trial
before an international military
tribunal in which all accused would be
given every opportunity to present their
cases the tribunal would be committed to
strict rules of evidence growing out of
centuries of legal experience and the
development of law and order among
nations serious and heated debate went
on for many months among the delegates
to the big four powers finally
culminating in a charter agreement at
the London conference in August of 1945
establishing the International Military
Tribunal the Palace of Justice at
Nuremberg was selected because Nuremberg
had been the site of the huge Nazi Party
rallies the horror story of Nazism began
unfolding before the eyes and ears of
the world at Nuremberg on November 20
1945 the case was titled in the matter
of the United States of America the
French Republic the United Kingdom of
Great Britain em Northern Ireland and
the Union of Soviet Socialist Republics
versus Herman Wilhelm Goering and 21
other major Nazi leaders the 66 page
indictment of four counts charged a
Commons conspiracy to sea
power establish a totalitarian regime
plan prepare initiate and wage wars of
aggression the violation of the laws of
war crimes against peace crimes against
humanity and crimes of persecution and
extermination now the Nazis had
meticulously recorded by documentation
film and photography almost all of their
atrocities because tens of thousands of
pieces of documentary evidence had been
captured by the US and Allied forces
most facts presented at the trials were
incapable of being denied or defended of
22 defendants in the major Nazi leader's
case 19 were held accountable for their
crimes individually not collectively 12
were sentenced to death by hanging 10
were hanged on October 16 1946 and four
hours before Goering was to be hanged he
swallowed a cyanide capsule which he had
been able to hide on his body
on may 8 1945 when the war ended I was
on my first job in Detroit with a
freelance court reporting agency
publicity about the impending trials was
on the front pages of the newspapers all
across the country
and in the movie theatres on the
Movietone news reels we did not have
television at that time then into our
Detroit office one day came a flyer from
the United States War Department to
change my life significantly
approximately 26 court reporters were
being recruited from all over the United
States to go to Germany to report not
only goings trial but the 12 subsequent
trials of which the Nazi doctors trial
was the first I applied immediately
wondering if I could possibly be
selected
me with so little experience and with so
few to be selected
I waited anxiously in Detroit to hear
from the War Department and I soon heard
I was too young I had to be 21 and I was
only 20 so the next month in Detroit
were unbearable for me as I just tried
to grow old as fast as I could the first
wave of reporters had already been
selected for Gehrig's trial but as soon
as I was 21 I signed a contract with the
War Department and received my orders in
late October 1946 assigned to the office
of chief of counsel for war crimes
Nuremberg Germany on November 6 1946
I arrived in cold snowy bombed out
Nuremberg presented my orders to the
proper military authorities and was
driven to my first assigned home which I
shared for several months with one young
British woman and one young French woman
on the Allied payroll neither of whom
could I understand
for security reasons we were picked up
every morning at our front gate by a
displaced person on the Allied payroll
in a German car and driven to the iron
gates of the Palace of Justice
now with the trial of the major Nazi
leaders over the British the French and
the Soviets packed up and went to their
separate zones in Germany to try other
defendants however many of their
language experts stayed on to work on
the 12 subsequent trials on October 25
1946 the United States only filed an
indictment against 20 Nazi doctors and
three medical assistants and titled the
United States of America versus Karl
Brandt Italia and thus commenced the
first and most horrifying of the 12
subsequent trials I wanted this trial
more than any of the others including
Daring's trial and I was one of the six
reporters selected to report it from the
beginning to the end now who were these
defendants in the doctor's case Carl
Brown was not only Hitler's personal
physician but he was the chief architect
of the program and the machinery which
turned doctors who had taken the oath of
Hippocrates to heal and cure turned into
doctors who became torturers and
murderers in most cases they were
distinguished Germans scientists Chiefs
surgeons and physicians and Institutes
clinics hospitals and universities all
throughout Germany they were the doctors
at the concentration camps who performed
the grisly medical experiments all very
sadistic men and one woman with what
crimes were they charged with the
outright murder of political prisoners
civilians intellectual dissidents non
German nationals Catholic and Protestant
clergy and prisoners of war through
medical experimentation without their
consent in the name of scientific
medical research those who did not die
or who were not murdered suffered
torture maiming and permanent
disfigurement and disability
the victims were nameless ordered like
cattle in wholesale lots of 200 Jews in
good physical condition fifty gypsies
500 tubercular poles 1,000 Russian
prisoners of war the 23 doctors and
medical assistants were charged with 12
major experiments carried out from 1939
to 1945 at Auschwitz
involved Dachau ravensbrück nots filer
Saxon housing and other camps
the first experiment charged with
high-altitude victims were locked in
airtight ball-shaped compartments and
the pressure was altered to simulate
high-altitude atmospheric conditions up
to sixty eight thousand feet without
oxygen the approximately two hundred
victims were Russian and Polish Jews who
were termed professional criminals why
because they had been condemned for
racial shame consisting of marriage or
intercourse between non-aryans and
Aryans the term given to pure blooded
Germans their punishment was the torture
of over 120 and the murder of 70 to 80
the second experiment was freezing
conducted to determine the most
effective means of hitting severely
chilled or frozen people the victims
were placed in long narrow tanks of ice
water for up to three hours at which
point death occurred or by keeping them
outdoors naked nine to 14 hours in
sub-freezing temperatures they screamed
in pain as parts of their bodies froze
rewarming of those who did not die was
most effective by very hot baths then
Heinrich Himmler chief of the Gestapo
and one of the major Nazi leaders who
committed suicide after his capture by
the British and therefore was never
tried ordered rewarming by naked women
at one point four gypsy prostitutes
themselves prisoners were produced from
ravensbrück concentration camp and the
chill to unconsciousness naked male
victim was placed between
two naked women indicating the obscene
sickness of Himmler and his doctors
malaria experiments were conducted to a
German prisoners of war Russians
yugoslavs
and a large number of Polish Catholic
priests who were infected with malaria
through controlled infected mosquito
bites or by the injections of malaria
infected blood these these victims
suffered permanent disability and
approximately 400 deaths one-third of
the total number of experimental
subjects mustard gas experiments were
conducted to devout to investigate the
most effective treatment of mustard gas
wounds one drop of a liquid gas
substance was applied to the lower arm
of the experimental subject ten hours
later burns appeared and spread over the
entire body wherever drops contacted the
skin photos were taken daily fatality
started occurring after the fifth day
greater parts of the lungs and other
organs were eaten away some of the
victims were forced to enter the gas
chamber smash small ampules of liquid
gas and inhale the vapor with the same
results their lungs were destroyed of
approximately 220 victims over 50 died
the fifth experiment was sulfanilamide
I'm not going to detail every one of
these experiments for you because they
are all in the book one of the most
savage sadistic and inhuman experiments
was bone muscle and nerve regeneration
and bone transplantation in which whole
sections of bone whole legs taken off at
the hips muscles nerves arms including
scapula's were removed from healthy
victims and attempted be transplanted to
other healthy victims these were
predominantly young Polish women which
resulted for the most part in death but
for those who lived mutilation and
permanent disability the seventh
experiment of seawater to develop a
method of making sea water drinkable the
victims were German Czech and polish
gypsies deprived of food and given only
brackish yellow sea water for days
resulting in excruciating pain foaming
at the mouth and eventually in most
cases madness one of the most dramatic
courtroom scenes occurred during my turn
at the courtroom Karl Holland Rainer a
dark-haired man of small stature nervous
and very excitable assumed the witness
stand
the main courtroom of the Palace of
Justice ruled very large before him it
was June 27 1947 now witness for what
reasons were you arrested by the Gestapo
I'm 29 May 1944 the question was asked
in English and simultaneously
interpreted into German the answer given
in German interpreted through the
English Channel of my earphones was
because I am a gypsy of mixed blood the
Reich citizenship law dated September 15
1935 red Jews and gypsies cannot become
citizens the law for the protection of
German blood and German honor dated
November 14 1935 another of the infamous
Nuremberg Laws read a marriage shall
furthermore not be contracted if the
progeny to be expected from it would
endanger the purity of German blood
Carl holder Rayner was first sent to
Auschwitz then to Buchenwald and then
Dachau where sea water experiments
tortured his mind and body for days
question do you think you would be able
to recognize that doctor if you saw him
today
answer yes immediately I would recognize
him at once question would you kindly
stand up from your witness chair take
your earphones off and proceed over to
the defendants dock and see if you can
recognize the professor that you met at
Dachau everyone in the courtroom waited
tensely I watched this little man as he
stood up he paused for just a moment
his eyes seemingly fixed on a doctor in
the second row of the prisoners bucks
then in a flash he was gone from the
witness stand seeming to almost leap
over the ends of the German Defense
Council stables he appeared to be almost
flying through the air toward the
prisoner's dock with his right arm
stretched high reaching for doctor
beagle buck the consulting physician to
the German air force amid the scramble
of defense counsel bending away from him
and momentary shock and confusion in
that courtroom three of our American
military policemen rushed from behind
the prisoners dock and grabbed this
little man almost in mid-air
Bewdley bent on delivering his own brand
of justice I did not see a weapon but I
was told later by an American military
police officer that he had been able to
hide a dagger on his person the eighth
experiment was epidemic Jonas the ninth
experiment was sterilization conducted
on Russian prisoners of war in Polish
Jews to develop a
suitable method for the sterilization of
millions of people by radiation drugs
and surgery in a planned mass genocide
of large population groups this resulted
in horrible physical and mental pain and
anguish the tenth experiment was typhus
conducted to determine the effectiveness
of vaccines the experimental subjects
were not only German criminals taken
from their own jails but poles Russians
Frenchmen and prisoners of war the
purpose was to manufacture a typhus
convalescent serum infection was
accomplished by laceration of the skin
and the introduction of a typhus culture
by contagious lice or by the intravenous
or intramuscular injection of fresh
blood containing the typhus virus now to
maintain a constant source of infected
fresh blood three to five inmates per
month were artificially infected with
typhus these victims became raving mad
suffered delirium and over 90 percent
died a slow and frightful death and in
Denver we have a survivor of this
experiment who told me that of 50 men
selected from his block at Buchenwald
only 17 survived and he was one of them
the electron's experiment was poisoned
now some of these 12 experiments had
absolutely no scientific objective to
heal or cure but rather to kill or
exterminate and this was one of them
poison bullets were shot into Russian
prisoners of war not to test an antidote
for poison but to time how fast death
occurred taking up to two hours and nine
minutes poison was also secretly
administered
in food and the doctors stood behind
curtains to watch the reactions these
victims suffered excruciating torture
and all died or were deliberately killed
to permit autopsies the last major
experiment was incendiary bomb to test
the effect of pharmaceutical
preparations on phosphorus burns the
victims were inflicted with phosphorus
from the bombs and then the wounds
ignited burning the skin for up to 68
seconds before extinguishing resulting
in intense pain and suffering at one
time 112 Jews were selected to complete
a skeleton collection for the University
of the right University in Strasbourg
France under Nazi occupation photographs
and anthropological measurements were
taken and the victims were killed and
defleshed and on the cover of the book
is the picture of the doctor who was not
a doctor a medical assistant who was in
charge of this experiment military
tribunal was established on October 25
1946 to hear the medical case concluded
in on July 19 1947 after the
introduction of 1471 pieces of
documentary evidence for doctors
including Carl brunt were sentenced to
death by hanging
five to life imprisonment
two to twenty years 1 to 15 years 1 to
10 years and 7 were found not guilty and
released at Carl Brandt's execution on
November 2 1948
before he fell through the tap trapdoor
he declared it is no shame to stand on
the scaffold I served my fatherland as
others before me there was not one
scintilla of any kind of remorse shown
on the part of any one of these doctors
or assistants including the seven who
were acquitted the court in its detailed
final judgment set forth ten points
regarding permissible medical
experiments known as the Nuremberg code
which was the starting point for
research guidelines the code has been
extended by the 1964 Declaration of
Helsinki with subsequent additions and
continues in use today
now all of this Horror Story was to be
the final solution of the Jewish
Question here were people who had this
happen to them just for being who they
were this was coordinated evil and
hatred on a scale unprecedented by a
modern civilized society of my heritage
I am NOT Jewish
I am half German a society that produced
such brilliant writers composers and
scientists as Goethe Khan Bach Beethoven
and yes bogner Hitler's favorite vessel
roentgen and Einstein Adolf Hitler was
not criminally I'm saying he was
criminally sane a link to our common
humanity which should make us all think
about it
our humanity is also linked to the six
million Jews and the millions of
non-jews who made up the almost 11
million victims of the Holocaust
now one cannot easily comprehend that
figure until one sees a copy of the
orders at the Treblinka death camp in
Poland for example for the extermination
of 14,000 per day now the non-jewish
world did not talk much about this
educate about it or commemorate it for
almost 30 years after it happened and I
could never understand why then on
November 1 1978 while I was chief
reporter of debates in the United States
House of Representatives President Jimmy
Carter by executive order established
the President's Commission on the
Holocaust appointing the later Nobel
laureate Elie Wiesel as chairman on
April 2 1979 President Carter by
Proclamation designated April 28 and 29
1979 as days of remembrance of victims
of the Holocaust asking the people of
the United States to observe this solemn
anniversary of the liberation of
by US Armed Forces on April 28 and 29 of
1945 this is a story of the mass
violation of basic human rights in the
dignity of life of indifference to evil
of people who knew and kept silent of
heads of state who looked the other way
including our own and our church leaders
too many church leaders who did not
speak out against what was happening I
was neither a witness nor a victim but I
was a verbatim court reporter of the
words that came from their mouths at
Nuremberg on April 12 1945 General
Dwight Eisenhower supreme commander of
the Allied forces in Europe wrote a
letter to Chief of Staff General George
Marshall describing his first visit to
one of the camps by US forces quote the
things I saw beggar description the
visual evidence and the verbal testimony
of starvation cruelty and bestiality
were so overpowering as to leave me a
bit sick in one room where there were
piled up twenty or thirty naked men
killed by starvation George Patton would
not even enter he said he would get sick
if he did so I made the visit
deliberately in order to be in a
position to give first-hand evidence of
these things if ever in the future there
develops a tendency to charge these
allegations merely due propaganda and
that is precisely what is happening
throughout the world today with the
insidious spread of Holocaust denial I
have been seriously confronted twice by
Holocaust deniers the largest
organization
in the United States is the Institute
for historical review based in Newport
Beach California I was first confronted
by them in 1997 when I was speaking at
the antlers Hotel in Colorado Springs to
judges and lawyers a third attorney came
up to us before we got started and said
someone is handing out propaganda in the
to the lawyers who are registering at
that moment this man came bounding up
across the floor to me with a big smile
on his face handed me three sheets of a
document
and asked me if I was familiar with
their Institute I looked at the title
and said I am very familiar with your
Institute Institute for historical
review but you do not have the correct
title at the top it should be Institute
for historical revision and Holocaust
denial been his demeanor changed
he became hostile to me and challenged
me to debate him not only on the
Holocaust but on the Nuremberg war
crimes trials which you understand were
a staged production put on by the four
countries and all of the photographs are
fake I said to him I will not only not
debate you I will not dignify with an
answer any question you put to me I have
nothing further to say to you those who
cannot remember the past are condemned
to repeat it and we have not remembered
well we must learn from the lessons of
the past to help us overcome our hatreds
and prejudices of today to structure our
future with faith hope and dedication to
humanity with international
understanding peace and justice
thank you very much for listening now
we're going to take questions first one
side of the room and then the next
about
Tyrande connection
pardon me Oh the tattoos removed from
the prisoners right that was uh Elsa
Koch that was in another trial that I
did not report but yes indeed that did
occur especially with downed Airmen u.s.
airman who had tattoos they made
lampshades out of them and other items
but that was not part of my trial so I
cannot give you details on that
what was the rationale behind the
letting the certain doctors off
completely how could they be dismissed
from their crimes her question was what
was the rationale for letting the seven
doctors off and not be accountable for
their crimes I was shocked at this as
many of us were I would not have been
shocked had there been three doctors
acquitted but you have to remember that
this was the world was watching these
trials the international press was there
from 20 different countries and there
had never been trials like these in the
history of civilization before I feel
that the judges especially the American
judges who were the judges on the 12
subsequent trials bent over backwards to
show the world that these were not
trials of the victors over the
vanquished but rather of justice over
evil
did you get to meet Rudolf Hess and
write of them Guren fights all Goering
and Albert Speers did you get them no
time to shine I was too young when that
trial went on and I did not report that
trial I was reading in Detroit to get
old enough to get there to report the
doctor's trial which was the trial I
wanted with no assurance that I was
going to get it but I did yes especially
the doctors trial the doctors were not
the political or military leaders they
were the educated scientists who had
sworn to do no harm to their patients
they were in totally different category
I wanted to take their testimony to font
try to to try to understand how they
could in my book I go through in great
detail every single one of these
experiments through the testimony of the
witnesses whom I actually reported and
recorded their words yeah it was yours
okay he's got one here thank you
Oh since the Nazis were known for
keeping meticulous records of all of
this and and all the other things which
they did how do you feel about the
ethical question whether or not any of
the findings which they got from this
horrific work to make it usable in the
scientific community if it has any use I
mean is there an ethical question in
your mind whether my mind very very much
an ethical question that question has
been been debated for all of these years
by doctors but I felt that from what I
learned at Nuremberg these experiments
were not conducted with proper medical
experimental protocols in place and I
felt that it was totally unethical
because they had performed the
experiments on these victims to the
point of death without their consent
this is a question that is better
answered by the doctor
I have a daughter who is a court
reporter she just graduated recently and
she had four years of training and I was
just interested in what kind of training
did you have and were there very many
court reporters at that time was it a
pretty new field at that time and were
you able to tell people that you had to
get their report in the ER and they had
to slow down because I understand that
she can do that now court reporters have
been the first court reporters were in
the 1800s and they were newspaper
reporters for the Boston Globe and they
sat in the chambers in Congress and
wrote in longhand and they were called
reporters now our court reporters now
are required to go through two to four
years of education they become broadcast
captioners on real-time it is an
expanding field I graduated from a
business college in Chicago I use the
Gregg shorthand system of reporting
which is no longer in existence you know
what that is I passed a high-speed
National Court Reporters Association
examination at 260 words a minute which
is what there were only four of us in
the country at that time writing Gregg
shorthand in pen and ink but we had to
have that you have to you have to pass
the UM the high speeds required in the
testing procedures the state of Colorado
requires
225 words a minute and when I went to
Congress I read I wrote at 260 words a
minute by the time I got there the world
speed champion writes at 280 words a
minute so I mean it's a great feel it is
great and she asks you if you have to
slow them down in Nuremberg when I you
know when I do a longer a full
presentation I tell about how the court
reporters work Nuremberg we had half
shorthand reporters like I was with a
pen and a reporter's notebook half steno
type reporters and we could never nor in
Congress can we ever interrupt Ted
Kennedy anybody else who's speaking
especially a Ted Kennedy who never m's a
sentence and I reported him over a
period of three years but you just have
to sometimes we had congressmen who
loved to reel off a sentence as did Jim
Wright in Texas in Spanish and then we
wrote sounds and I went to the
congressman later and asked him to
translate for me or spell those Spanish
words in Spanish if that's what he
wanted to see in the congressional
record which nobody else could read but
in the courtroom you can if you get
behind or if you have a witness that is
not intelligible and you can't
understand it but I just don't ever
remember having to stop anybody now in
the nürnberg the interpreters are the
ones who had the problems because we
reporters had to wait for the
interpreters to translate the the words
and I don't know German but I understand
that in German the verb comes at the end
of the sentence
and so the interpreter had to wait until
the end of the sentence to get the verb
and the current reporter waited for the
interpreter and then he telescope that
sentence as fast as he possibly could
because the next sentence is already
being spoken but at any rate if a
reporter is qualified they can handle it
yes two questions
worthy were there other reporters who
translate or were they only transcribed
in English for the Nuremberg trials and
when did you decide to write your book
and tell us about that I'm going to
answer your second question first Tony
thank you very much for it this
reporting these trials caused me so many
problems I was so horrified by it that
when as soon as I got back to this
country I started having nightmares and
I was always escaping through a tunnel
for some reason with four or five small
children I was escaping from a
concentration camp and therefore it
might had been Tara seeing the
children's camp in a tunnel
and I was trying to keep these children
quiet because the Nazi guard was
marching back and forth along the barbed
wire fence with his bayonetted rifle I
didn't want the guard to hear the
children I kept looking for the light at
the end of that tunnel this went on for
three years and it was pure torture for
me and I was so horrified that I could
not speak about it I have empathy with
these survivors and I don't know whether
we have
I was in this room but I've spoken to I
think most of them in the Jewish
community here in Denver but I was so
horrified I never talked about it I
never talked about it I was in the
unofficial reporter in the Denver
District Court within eight years after
I got back from Nuremberg and I didn't
talk about it no one talked about it and
I just shoved it all in the back of my
mind and thought nothing about it until
1987 when in Denver we had a high school
teacher in a high school in Aurora who
referred to the Holocaust to her senior
students as the whole of Hawks and the
she claimed that she was trying to to
make her students do critical thinking
that at any rate I I was just livid and
I decided to get my material and
photographs and in my full presentation
I do a PowerPoint I couldn't do it here
tonight because of time but I have 38
captured German film and I got all of
that out which I had stored in boxes for
40 years and I put together a lecture
which I started giving a 1989 all over
the countries thousands and thousands of
students who were my target audiences
and then in 1995 the Steven Spielberg
Foundation interviewed me here in Denver
and I was beginning to get
confrontations by Holocaust deniers
claiming that it never happened and in
1999 I was speaking at the Long Beach
Hilton hotel to a good-sized audience
the LA Times gave me huge publicity in
advance
the day before and as a result the
Hilton Hotel received calls from quote
historians asking where and when in the
hotel I would be speaking and not
whether they could attend the hotel told
them it was a private professional
Association not open to the public they
demanded that they be allowed to go in
and the hotel called me the night before
I flew him to LA and asked me to
register under an assumed name they
would put on additional security
I flew in registered under another name
and I spoke on Saturday afternoon to
this large group my presentation is
about an hour and a half long including
the slides and at the end when people
were asking me questions suddenly the
the doors to the right of me flew open
an armed security guard with a gun on
his yep came up to me on the podium and
said quietly I have to take you off the
podium right now I knew something was
happening and I went right with him
behind the podium out the door into an
elevator there and down to the basement
for protection so at that time I decided
it's time I write this book and recently
a doctor asked me how I felt
doctors have received the book extremely
well asked me how I felt now that I have
the book finished and I said I have
found the light at the end of that
tunnel
[Applause]
they'll exist if so where are they
stored there in archives in Maryland I
say okay my notes of the Nuremberg
trials I said okay they're all in
archives and I want to tell you that the
court reporters transcript of the
doctor's trial is eleven thousand five
hundred thirty eight pages long in
archives and the staff the attorneys and
staff at Nuremberg condensed those
eleven thousand pages down to 1300 which
you can get in one of the 42 volumes in
the Denver Public Library on the fifth
floor in the government documents
section volumes 1 and part of volume 2
and it was this is my transcript and it
is from the 1,300 pages that I have
prepared this book and I have gotten
what I considered to be the most
important points and put them in this
book so the book now you can read the
story for 300 pages instead of 11,000
somebody back there has a question
are you scheduled to give your extended
lecture with the PowerPoint at any time
in the Denver area in the next year I
hate to tell you this but I am moving to
Houston in December however I do not
have I am booked to my eyeballs right
now
into September 2006 around the country
but I don't have I just did Regis
University on March 29 to an overflow
crowd there which CNN from Los Angeles
filmed but I'm sorry to tell you that I
don't have anything booked and I don't
have time I have a commitment to one
Denver doctor to speak to a group of
doctors and dentists before I leave town
there's somebody here how did you get
the photographs and the other
memorabilia that you have the
photographs the one in the book know
that you were saying that you have are I
got them when I was in Nuremberg they
were given to us if we wanted them in
the court reporters office now the the
pictures that I have in the book in in
the book at one point I have a bin of
legs taken off at the hips
now those pictures were received in
evidence in Nuremberg and I had copies
of them I mean for some reason I grabbed
on to everything I could get or that
they offered there and as far as the mug
shots of all of the doctors in the book
the Holocaust Museum in Washington DC at
my request sent the photographs to my
publisher
in Boulder this is Carl brunt and when
you read my book you will read about my
first day going into the courtroom and
looking at all of the defendants and
scanning those defendants in the two
roles right to left and Carl Brown sat
in the first seat in the first role on
the left seat number one none of the
other doctors paid attention to me as I
looked this was before I started writing
except this one and he was staring into
my eyes with such evil and felt intently
that I was shocked I felt a chill and
then I put my head down to start writing
the Brigadier General Telford Taylor who
prosecuted that trial noticed it and he
said to me shortly after that that he
felt it was because I was tall blond and
blue-eyed his areum but that's how I got
the photographs in the u.s. a Holocaust
Museum in Washington DC I have
contributed for degraaf's
in the book I have a picture of the
doctors in the doc and I contributed
that photograph to the Museum in
Washington DC and several others in
there that I have okay next next
you know after reporting on such hatred
and seeing such hatred in someone eyes
how do you keep hope for Humanity
how do you stay positive oh I belong to
the optimist club I do I'm an optimist
yes yes I'll have young people responded
to my presentation very well we have
done a great job in Denver of educated
the children for 12 years I was on the
Anne Frank
art and writing competition with Teresa
messengerís chairman who was in the back
of the room and we worked well I think
we started that first year educating 8
to 18 in competition and we had 56
entries I believe the first year 51 and
the last year 2002 yeah we were close to
4,000 we just missed it by about 20 we
were 4,000 or 800 and slam yes it is
for 12 years we work together to educate
the students in Denver in all the
schools
we even had entries from other states
yes
how large was the network of doctors in
Germany how would you know how many
there were that were involved in these
experiments besides your cases that you
were on and how would that have affected
the medical profession in Germany
afterwards seeing as they let off seven
of the more important criminals how
would how would you trust the German
physicians after the war the German
physicians after there were I understood
that there were between two and three
hundred German doctors who were involved
in experiments but we only were able to
get twenty now in 1945 a very important
trial occurred in Dachau this was an
American military court trial in which
they they convicted dr. Schelling
some of the most infamous of the doctors
and hanged them there I mean we hanged a
you know seven Dachau hanged close to 40
now I do not know I cannot answer a
question about the doctors subsequently
but I think it's not a happy answer
there are too many doctors who were
involved in these experiments who got
away and who are still involved today
even in their 80s in the medical
practice I hope I am correct on that I
have my doctor expert up here yes
given the number of genocide Oh
massacres that have occurred in the last
50 years like Indonesia Cambodia Rwanda
what do you think we've learned the
answer to your question is we haven't
that's all I can say genocides are
continuing we haven't had I think that's
a question that I point out in my book
why haven't we learned the lessons
this is dr. Ming Lee tried in absentia
at your trial you know he asked a good
question
everybody wants to know about dr.
Mengele Josef Mengele who was the the
angel of death at Auschwitz who
experimented on children who would stand
at the ramp and select the the pregnant
Jews to save them so that when their
babies were born he could experiment on
them Mengele was hiding in a stable in
Germany all the time I worked there he
got away
he actually was in Auschwitz when the
Russian armies are got to Auschwitz and
he knew it would the EM was coming so he
ne his band of six or seven left and
started walking to Germany and when they
got to the border by that time American
military policemen were at the borders
and checked the information on these
people uh they uh he gave his name Josef
Mengele it meant nothing to an American
GI or to anybody at that time and so he
was released and his family were very
wealthy manufacturers in Bavaria and
they were able to hide him
in a stable I mean as a stablehand
on a farm in area until he escaped to
South America okay Charles